rongeur poisson lapin ou encore primate
l’expérimentation animale est utilisée
depuis des lustres pour faire avancer la
science
mais aujourd'hui tandis que ces
expériences en laboratoire sont de plus
en plus pointées du doigt et font
l'objet de nombreuses critiques c'est un
problème politique l'expérimentation
animale certains professionnels qui
mènent ce genre d’études n’hésitent plus
aujourd'hui à se livrer selon une
récente étude 86% des personnes qui
travaillent dans ces laboratoires ont
déjà ressenti un sentiment de route
souffert d'insomnie ou même de Burn Out
et tous ces symptômes portent un nom la
fatigue compressionnelle on commence à
mettre un monstre sur quelque chose que
forcément un jour ou l'autre tout le
monde a ressenti alors faut-il arrêter
les expérimentations sur les animaux
alors la question est posée faut-il
arrêter alors c'est un débat qui ça a
presque 100 ans ce débat mais il y a
ceux qui pensent qu'il faut arrêter on
va leur rétorquer alors dans ces cas-là
comment est-ce qu'on fait avancer la
science et sur qui on teste les produits
voilà c'est tout le débat donc je vais
commencer par les oui parce que bien sûr
Gilles Verdez il est pour la raie des
expérimentations sur les animaux
immédiat un animal voit un homme
immédiat avec ça sur les hommes on
expire vraiment plus sur les animaux
alors heureusement aujourd'hui il y a
des réglementations très précises il y a
des lois qui sont passées mais néanmoins
ils subsistent en cas d'urgence absolue
scientifique le droit d'expérimenter sur
des animaux c'est de la barbarie ça
devrait être condamné il faut arrêter
immédiatement il y a pas d'autre
solution que tu ne pourrais pas prendre
bah tant pis c'est pas grave parce que
si ces médicaments sont destinés à des
hommes on n'a pas à faire souffrir des
animaux solution alors il y a pas de
solution en tout cas le cancer on a nos
familles
je me dis bah
l'alimentation c'est pas que pour les
médicaments c'est aussi pour des rouges
à lèvres des conneries comme ça
là je parle honnêtement on va là on
parle pour la santé merci tout ce qui
est tout ce qui est cosmétique les
roulettes évidemment bah c'est pour
arrêter de massacrer des animaux pour
que des gens soient mieux maquillés
j'ai un beagle un chien de chasse
anglaise beaucoup quel chien le plus
utilisé pour l'expérimentation animale
c'est un chien qui est tellement gentil
on lui fout des électrodes sur la tête
on le torture et le lendemain il fait la
tête et la fête quand il vous voit alors
qu'il s'est il va encore être torturé
une journée de plus je suis chien qui ne
voit jamais une herbe qui ne voit jamais
la lumière du jour etc c'est un vrai
scandale normalement les animaux moi
j'adore on ne le fait pas mais le
problème alors qu'est-ce qu'on fait
est-ce qu'on le fait sur les humains
après parce qu'il faut bien que là non
mais attends il faut bien qu'on avance
tout le monde sera d'accord aujourd'hui
il faut qu'on soigne il faut aujourd'hui
l'espérance de vie aller plus longue
c'est triste mais grâce à ça aussi donc
ok moi je veux qu'il y ait aucun animaux
il y a pas de test il ne meurt pas c'est
quoi l'autre solution et de quel droit
vous fait mourir des animaux il voulait
tourner
mais c'est pas la question du droit si
tu es bien heureux de CRE 90 plutôt qu'à
50 au jour d'aujourd'hui on a évolué et
c'est triste à dire mais c'est grâce à
ça et ben moi ça me gênerait pas qu'on
meurt à 80 plutôt 90 sans faire souffrir
les animaux aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'on
gagne aujourd'hui avant que tu auras ça
c'est pas forcément attention que c'est
pas forcément pour des gens de 80 ans
comme tu dis ça parfois c'est le sang
pour des enfants des maladies enfantines
moi c'est un cas de conscience je suis
contre la souffrance animale vraiment ça
ça me fait mal au cœur mais
malheureusement pour sauver des enfants
des gens exactement il faut bien tester
des médicaments des traitements on va
pas faire un débat voilà on va resserrer
évidemment quand c'est inutile ou
superflu ou accessoires évidemment
quelque chose se pose pas et d'ailleurs
je crois que ça change et je crois que
c'est interdit aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il y a un débat qui est ouvert je
vais demander à Sophia vous je suis pas
pour le fait compter sur les animaux
mais comme il l'a dit tant qu'on sait
pas l'autre solution on n'a pas le choix
je t'aime beaucoup tu sais depuis il y a
beaucoup de choses qu'on a en commun
tous les deux on va partir faire Pékin
Express
sur les animaux les méthodes de
substitution en fait qui ont été testées
maintenant c'est sur des tissus des
cellules humaines donc ça existe il y a
des modélisations aussi par ordinateur
ce qu'on appelle la méthode in silico
qui est une méthode qui apparemment
fonctionne aussi et on aimerait aussi
mettre en place des des tests sur la
base du volontariat c'est à dire sur des
personnes ça ça existe beaucoup
dans la pharmacopée entre autres
d'ailleurs il y a des gens qui testent
des médicaments etc qui sont d'accord
pour faire un panel de test on pourrait
arrêter les expérimentations sur les
animaux en tout cas sur certaines choses
parce que a priori aussi les études
démontrent que il y a énormément
d'expérience qui sont faites sur les
animaux et qui finalement ne sont pas
probantes sur les hommes après
la science il faut tester pour savoir ce
qui fonctionne ou pas maintenant on le
sait on sait qu'il y a certaines
méthodes qui ne fonctionnent pas donc on
le sait et on continue à et on continue
evil et en plus il y a pas de
réglementation sur la cruauté etc enfin
sur la torture et sur les conditions en
laboratoire des animaux
alors la règle dans l'élevage oui de
l'hygiène dans les restaurants oui on
est d'accord c'est la règle elle est
quand même un peu hypocrite les
avantages et ce que la phrase c'est les
avantages escomptés doivent l'emporter
sur les préjudices aux animaux vous
voyez que ça laisse quand même la place
au laboratoire
donc ça laisse trop de place pour moi
c'est pas assez restrictif et quand vous
dites les cosmétiques c'est interdit
bien sûr mais les laboratoires il y a de
l'hypocrisie il y en a qui testent des
choses pour après en tirer avantage sur
d'autres produits donc l'hypocrisie elle
est là il faut si on arrête pas
définitivement on aura toujours je pense
Gilles que s'il y avait un moyen de
tester l'ensemble des produits sur des
choses différentes des cellules souches
ou pas
synthétique ou pas ou modéliser des des
schémas ou pas je pense que globalement
que de matériel très cher ou lors de
d'autres choses bah si une souris ça
coûte que dalle
produit à vitesse grand V et on les fait
souffrir à vitesse qu'on veut aussi je
suis désolé
non plus d'ailleurs arrêtez allez
coûteuses donc les poissons
enfin un poisson rouge excusez-moi quoi
un poisson rouge
derrière vous quoi les poissons ils vous
ont demandé quoi les poissons rouges
c'est le bordel c'est enfin le poisson
rouge il fait le tour de poker il a
oublié déjà ce qui est arrivé
beau le bus
c'est un double budget le débat qu'on va
on ne fera pas le débat et vous avez
raison c'est qu'il y a pas de hiérarchie
dans la souffrance animale j'avais
raison vous avez raison de vous
présenter bien évidemment mais c'est
vrai que une souris vaut un Castaldi
voilà
ah bah c'est sûr il y a un poisson rouge
ou un Verdez je vais vous dire ça c'est
sûr